ستكون الاشهر السته المقبله حاسمه من
نواحي عديده في المواجهه التي بداتها
روسيا بهذا العدوان
[موسيقى]
بايجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره اهلا بكم
الرئيس الروسي يقول ان بلاده تتعرض لما
وصفه بعدوان غير مسبوق لسحق اقتصادها
بينما اكد الرئيس الاوكراني ضروره هزيمه
ما وصفه بارهاب الطاقه الروسيه بجميع
اشكاله في حين قال رئيس المجلس الاوروبي
الى الاتفاق على سقف لاسعار الغاز امر
معقد
في سوريا دوريات المشتركه للقوات الروسيه
والتركيه لاول مره منذ اسابيع على قرن
خاضعه لسيطره ما تعرف بقوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه في حين حذر اردوغان واشنطن من
ان استمرارها في تزويد ما وصفها بالمنظمات
الارهابيه بالاسلحه سيجعل انقر تقوم بما
يقع على عاتقها
رغم الخساره امام فرنسا التي تاهلت الى
نهائي كاس العالم المنتخب المغربي يتصدر
مواقع التواصل الحضياء اسود الاطلس باشاده
واسعه عقب الاداء الكبير الذي قاموا به
بدايه البطوله ووصولهم الى الدور نصف
النهائي
مجلس الاحتياطي الفدراليه الامريكيه
يرفعوا سعر الفائده نصف نقطه مئويه لتصل
الى اعلى مستوى منذ 15 سنه وذلك في سياق
الجهود لخفض معدل التضخم المجلس اشار الى
ان سوق العمل لا يزال غير متوازن وانطلب
على الايدي العامله يتجاوز العروض بشكل
كبير
الى اللقاء